I want to continue in volume 4 and it's January the 5th, 1901 and the subject is obedience.
The Weezer said, "As I was outside of myself, I saw the confessor placing the intention
of the crucifixion.
I was afraid to submit myself, but Jesus told me, 'What can I do?
I cannot help obeying, because my humanity was made on purpose to obey."
That's John 1431, as well as all the other references in John where Jesus says, "I only
do what my father tells me to do.
I only say what my father tells me to say.
The father and I are one."
What you have here is Jesus acknowledging and responding to church authority.
What you find is that in exorcisms, Satan recognizes church authority as well and responds
to it.
This virtue of obedience, Jesus said, was so grafted within me that it can be said that
obedience is nature in me, now he's going to tell her, "I am obedience."
It was nature in me and the distinction dearest and most glorious to me, so much so that if
my humanity did not have this of its own, I would abhor it and I would never have united
myself to it.
This is the exact opposite of all the pride that you find in the rest of us.
You then, when you want to disobey, he said to Louisa, "You can do it, but you'll do
it by yourself.
I won't concur."
And all confused and seeing God so obedient, Louisa said, "I too want to obey and I submitted
myself," she said, "and Jesus shared with me the pains of the cross."
After this, Jesus transported me outside of myself and blessed Jesus gave me a kiss.
As he was doing this, a bitter breath came out of him and he was in the act of wanting
to pour his bitterness, but he didn't do it because he wanted to be told by me to do
it.
Immediately I said, "Do you want some reparation?
Let us do it together."
In this way, my reparations united to yours will have the effects of your reparations.
For if I do it on my own, I believe it would disgust you even more.
So I took his hand dripping with blood and kissing it, I recited the "Laudate Dominum"
praise the Lord prayer with the Gloria Patrick.
Jesus took one part and Louisa took the other to repair for the many evil works that are
committed, placing the intention of praising Jesus as many times for as many offenses as
he receives because of evil works.
Now moving it was to see Jesus praying, "I want to give you Romans 8.26."
For those who love God, everything works out.
Then I continued to do the same with the other hand placing the intention of praising him
for as many times and as many offenses that he receives because of the sins of causes.
And then his feet with the intention of praising him as many times for as many evil steps and
as many wrong paths which are covered, even under the appearance of piety and holiness.
Lastly, his heart with the intention of praising him for as many times as the human heart does
not palpitate and does not love and does not desire God.
My beloved Jesus seemed all refreshed by these reparations done together with him, but he
was not yet content.
Now notice that the reparations only have a great value if our reparations are associated
with Jesus' reparations so we take on his infinite merits.
And then we do them with the divine will so that they become divine reparations and therefore
they affect all souls past, present and future.
It seemed that Jesus wanted to pour.
So Louisa said to him, "Lord, if you want to pour, I pray you to do it."
So he poured his bitterness and then he said, "My daughter, how much men offend me.
But the time will come when I will chastise them in such a way that many little worms
will come out, which will produce clouds of mosquitoes, that will render them greatly
oppressed."
In other words, a plague of mosquitoes.
It sounds like one of the plagues of the book of Revelation.
And Louisa said, "Then afterwards, the pope will come out," he said.
And Louisa said, "Why would the pope come out?"
And he said, "He will come out to console the people because oppressed, tired, crushed,
betrayed by so many lies.
They themselves will look for the harbor of truth, and all humiliated, they will ask
the Holy Father to come into their midst to free them from so many evils and to place
them in the harbor of safety."
That's rather interesting.
We know that the Holy Father did come out to try and console people during the Second
World War.
So I want to give you Isaiah chapter 2 verses 6 to 20.
In other words, the pride of man has to be brought low if everything on this earth is
to be put back into God's order.
Louisa said, "Lord, will this perhaps happen after the wards you have spoken about the
other times?"
And he said, "Yes."
In other words, he's not referring to anything in World War I or II.
And Louisa said, "I wish I could die before these things happen."
He said, "Where would I go to stay then?"
"Allor, there are so many good souls in which you can stay," she said, "such that in comparing
myself to them how bad I see myself, but not paying any attention to me, Jesus disappeared."
I mean, the number of souls that would love him at Louisa's level were just not there.
So January 6, 1901, January 6, 1901, Jesus communicates himself to the three Magi.
So Louisa is meditating on the incidents after the birth of Jesus.
As I was outside of myself, I seemed to see the moment when the Holy Magi arrived at the
grotto of Bethlehem.
And as they arrived into the presence of the Holy infant, Jesus was pleased to let the
rays of his divinity shine externally, communicating himself to the Magi in three ways, through
love, through beauty, and through power.
In such a way that they remained enraptured and engrossed in the presence of the little
baby Jesus.
So much so that if the Lord had not withdrawn the rays of his divinity internally again,
they would remain there forever unable to move anymore.
Then as the baby withdrew his divinity, the Holy Magi returned into themselves.
They stirred themselves, stupefied, and seeing an excessive love so great, because through
the light that the Lord had given to them, that is the enlightenment, he let them understand
the mystery of the incarnation.
So I want to give you Sam 36 verse nine there in your light, Lord, we see light.
Then they stood up and they offered their gifts to the Queen Mother, and she spoke at
length with them, but I'm unable to say everything she said.
I can only remember that she inculcated in them strongly, not only their own salvation,
but also taking to heart the salvation of their people.
Only no fear even to lay down their lives to obtain this intent.
After this, Louisa said, "I withdrew inside of myself, and I found myself together with
Jesus.
He wanted me to tell him something, but I saw myself so bad and confused that I wouldn't
dare to tell him anything.
Seeing that I was not saying anything, he himself continued to speak about the Holy
Gile, telling me, by having communicated myself to the Magi in three ways, now we're going
to be talking about three effects that it has on them.
I obtained three effects for them, because I never communicate myself to souls uselessly.
Rather, they always receive some profit for themselves.
So as I communicated myself through love, they obtained detachment from themselves.
As I showed myself through beauty, they obtained contempt for earthly things, and when I showed
myself through power, their hearts remained all bound to me, and they obtained the bravery
to lay down their blood and lives for me."
Then he added, "And you, what do you want?
Tell me, do you love me?
How would you want to love me?"
Not knowing what to say as my confusion increased, I said, "Lord, I would want nothing but you.
And if you say to me, do you love me?
I have no words to be able to manifest it.
I can only say that I feel this conviction that no one may be able to prevail over me
in loving you."
Now, a lot of the saints have said that nobody will love you more than I do, but in Louise's
case, since she is brought into the divine level, then it's true, absolutely.
I feel this conviction that no one may be able to prevail over me in loving you, and that
I should be the first in loving you above everyone, and no one may be able to surpass
me.
But this does not content me yet.
In order to be content, I would want to love you with your own love.
That means to love Jesus divinely, which you can only do in the divine will.
So that I may be able to love you as you love yourself.
Ah, yes.
Only then would my concerns about loving you cease.
Content, one would say with my nonsense, "Jesus' class may tightly to himself that I could
see myself transmuted into him inside and out.
And he communicated part of his love to me, part because Louise is a creature and can only
take a small amount."
And of course, he's infinite.
And if I have a little jug and I fill the jug with water, you may have a gallon of water,
but there's no room in this jug for a gallon of water.
Once it's full, it's full.
So because Jesus is infinite and she's finite, then the overflowing of his love can only
go a certain distance.
So after this, Louise said, I returned into myself and it seemed to me that for as much
love as I'd given him so much, do I possess my good?
And if I love him little, I possess him little.
That's the very important thing, that loving and possession go together.
So January 9, 1901, the subject here now is union.
This morning I felt all oppressed and crushed, so much so that I went in search of relief.
My only good made me wait a long time for his coming.
And then, oncoming, he told me, "My daughter, did I not take your passions, miseries and
weaknesses upon myself for love of you?
Would you not want to take those of others upon yourself for love of me?"
Now there I want to give you Romans 13, 8 to 10, the debt of love that we owe the Lord
for others.
And then he added, "What I want is that you would be always united with me like a sun's
ray which remains always fixed in the center of the sun, on which receives life from the
sun as well as heat and splendor."
Suppose that a ray would depart from the center of the sun, what would become of it?
Immediately after leaving it would lose its life, light and heat and would return to darkness
and would be reduced to nothing.
Of course, that's what happened to Lucifer when he broke away from God, who is light,
that he himself became one who lost life, light and love and returned to darkness and
hatred and nothingness.
Such is the soul, Jesus said, "As long as she remains united with me in my center, it can
be said that she is like the sun's ray which lives, receives life from the sun, and goes
wherever the sun wants."
In some it remains at the complete disposal and at the will of the sun.
If then she distracts herself and disunites herself from me, there she is, all darkness
cold without feeling within herself that supernal spur of divine life.
So with this he disappeared.
So here he's telling us that this spirituality of living in the divine will presumes union
with God.
And if we move away from union with God at all, even for a few minutes, then we're shifting
into darkness and disintegration.
We must stay there in the fire of God's infinite love in order for him to be able to do what
he wants to do with us.
So January the 15th 1901, Jesus tells her that she forms his gracious martyrdom.
I have a little heading for myself over this one and it says stop complaining.
Since in the past days my beloved Jesus made himself seen as somehow indignant with the
world, this morning not seeing him come, I kept thinking to myself, who knows whether
he's not coming because he wants to send some chastisement.
And what have I done wrong?
But she knows that his staying away has nothing to do with her doing wrong, but she persists
in this opinion.
Because he wants to send chastisements, he does not dare to come to me, which is correct.
Okay, that should be a small ME.
My book has a capital M there.
How nice that while he wants to punish others, he has me get the greatest of chastisements,
which is the privation of him.
Now while I was saying this and other nonsense, my beloved Jesus made himself seen for just
a little and he said, my daughter, you form the greatest martyrdom for me because when
I have to send some chastisement, I cannot show myself to you, since you bind me everywhere
and you don't want me to do anything.
And as I don't come, you deafen me with your complaints, with your laments and your expectations,
so much so that while I'm occupied with chastising, I'm forced to think about you, to hear you,
and my heart is lacerated in seeing you in your painful state of my privation.
In fact, the most painful martyrdom is, in fact, the martyrdom of love, the martyrdom
of the heart.
And the more two persons love each other, the more painful these pains become, which arise
not from others, but from between themselves.
Therefore, be quiet, be calm, and do not want to increase my pains through your pains,
so he begs her to stop complaining.
Now he fails completely in that because as we go on in the volumes, she will continue
as if she had never heard this.
So probably this message lasts for as long as she writes it.
He disappeared, and I was left all mortified thinking that I formed the martyrdom of my
dear Jesus, and that in order not to make him suffer too much, when he does not come,
I must remain quiet.
But who can make this sacrifice, she says?
Who can make this one?
It seems impossible to me, and I will be forced to continue, I will be forced to continue
marturing each other, so she says, there's no way I can handle that, because when he goes,
she goes into a paroxysm of pain, and that's because of the extraordinary grace of union
with God that she has.
So January the 16th 1901, I have a VIP on this one, and this is about love, and especially
love for the souls and purgatory.
As I continue to see him a little indignant with the world, I wanted to occupy myself
with placating him, but he distracted me by saying, the love most acceptable to me, the
word in my book is charity.
The love most acceptable to me is towards those who are closest to me, and those who
are closest to me are the purging souls.
So this is love for the souls and purgatory, because they are confirmed in my grace.
In other words, they are saved, and they are guaranteed that they will go to heaven.
And there's no opposition between my will and theirs.
They live continuously in me, they ardently love me, and I am forced to see them suffer
within myself.
And the reason for that is they have not finished their purification.
And Hebrews 1214 says that nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
So I'm forced to see them suffer within myself, impotent to give themselves the slightest
relief on their own.
So once they go to purgatory, they can no longer help themselves.
They are completely, literally helpless.
Oh how tortured my heart is by the position of these souls, because they're not far away,
they're close to me, and not only close, but they're actually inside of me because they're
in the divine will.
And how pleasing to my heart, one who interests himself with them, this is very important.
Suppose you had a mother or a sister who lived with you in a state of sorrow, incapable of
helping themselves on their own, and then someone else, foreign, who lived outside of
your house, also in a state of sorrows, but capable of helping himself by himself.
Would you not be more pleased if someone occupied himself with relieving your mother and your
sister, because they are your family, rather than the foreign one who can help himself
on his own?
And Louisa said certainly, Lord, okay.
Now the foreign one who can help himself are those of us on earth, who can still go to
the sacraments, we can pray, we can do penance, we can help ourselves, but the ones who are
in need and can do nothing for themselves are the souls in purgatory.
Now, so that's number one, that's love for the souls in purgatory.
Now number two, the next paragraph is love for those who love Jesus on earth.
And then he added, "The second love most acceptable to my heart is for those who, though living
on this earth, are almost like purging souls.
That is, they love me, they always do my will, they interest themselves with my things as
if they were their own."
Now if these are oppressed or in need and in a state of sufferings and someone occupies
themselves with relieving them and helping them, this is more pleasing to me than it
was done to other people.
And again, it's because these souls are closer to him.
I just want to give you John 17 there, where in his priestly prayer Jesus prayed for his
disciples.
Now the third love, and you know, in our tradition we would have put this one first,
but he puts it first, and that's helping to save sinners.
Then Jesus disappeared, and as I found myself inside of myself, it seemed to me that those
things did not go according to truth, you see, traditionally we'd put it the other way around.
So on coming back my adorable Jesus made me understand that what he had told me was according
to truth.
There was only something left to say about the members separated from him, that is, those
who are sinners outside of grace therefore, that if one occupied themselves with reuniting
these members, this would be very acceptable to his heart.
The difference that exists is this, that of a sinner were oppressed in the midst of a
misfortune and one occupied himself not to convert him, but to relieve and help him materially.
The Lord would be more pleased if this were done for those who are in the order of grace.
In other words, Matthew 8.22 were to let the dead bury the dead, but if someone is disposed
and ready to come to grace, yes, it's a wonderful thing to help them.
In fact, if these suffer, it's always a product either of the love of God for them or their
love for God.
And if sinners suffer, the Lord sees in them the mark of guilt and their obstinate will.
Now you know from all of these writings, and it will become more and more clear as we go
along, that the greatest pain for the Lord is the obstinate will of a human being, because
all our happiness, joy, peace, everything lies in living in the divine will.
So this is how I seem to understand Louisa said, "After all, I leave the judgment of
those who have the right to judge me, whether this is according to truth or not."
So that's what she's saying, "I leave it to the church.
She can make her own decision."
January 24, 1901, Louisa asks Jesus for the reason for his privation, and he explains
it.
You're going to have this conversation many times.
Having spent the last days in silence, the past days in silence, and sometimes also without
my adorable Jesus, this morning as he came, I lamented to him saying, "Lord, how is it
that you do not come?
How things have changed."
It shows that it is either for the chastisement of my sins that you deprive me of your lovable
presence, or because you no longer want me in this state of victim.
He's always coming to these two wrong conclusions, and no matter how often he explains it, she
will still persist in this opinion.
"Oh, please, I beg you, let me know your will.
If I could not be oppressed when you wanted the sacrifice from me, much less can I do
it now."
Sorry.
"If I could not be oppressed when you wanted the sacrifice from me, much less can I do
it now, that finding me no longer worthy of being a victim, you want to take me out of
it.
Jesus doesn't want to take her out of it.
This is her own imagination."
Interrupting me, Jesus said, my daughter, by having made myself victim for mankind, taking
upon myself all weaknesses, miseries, and everything that man deserved before the divinity,
I represent the head of all.
And since I'm the head before the divinity, the human race finds in me a most powerful
shield that defends it, protects it, excuses it, and intercedes for it.
That's Hebrews 7.25.
The Lord ever lives to make intercession for us since his ascension.
Now, since you are in a state of being a victim soul, you come to represent for me the head
of the present generation.
Head means a leader.
Therefore, having to send some chastisement for the good of the people, and to call them
back to me, if I came to you as usual, by just showing myself to you, I'd already feel relieved
because he's meeting someone who loves him.
My pains are mitigated, and it happens to me as to someone who feels a strong pain and
screams because of the spasm.
If his pain ceased, he would no longer feel like screaming and sending out laments.
The same happens with me.
As my pains are mitigated, naturally, I no longer feel like sending out chastisements.
You then also, naturally, in seeing me, try to spare me and to take the pains of others
upon yourself.
Naturally means that it's your normal response to me, it's your response of love.
You cannot help doing your office of a victim soul before my presence, and if you didn't
do it, which can never be, I would be displeased with you.
This is the cause of my privation.
It's not because I want to punish your sins, I have other ways to purge you.
However, I will repay you.
On the days to come, I will double my visits, aren't you happy?
She said, "No Lord, I want you always, whatever the cause may be.
I do not give way to remaining a single day without you," and while I was saying this,
he disappeared and Louisa came back to herself.
So she's not ready to negotiate any absences at all.
So January 27, 1901, the establishment of faith is the establishment of charity or divine love.
As I was in my usual state, my adorable Jesus made himself seen for a little while, and
I don't know why.
He said to me, my daughter, the whole establishment of the Catholic faith is in the establishment
of charity or love, agape, love, divine love.
Let me read that again.
The whole establishment of the Catholic faith is the establishment of love, which unites
the heart and makes them live in me.
And throwing himself into my arms, he wanted me to refresh him, and after I did as much
as I could, he gave me tit for tat and he disappeared.
So I want to give you some things about love, which I've given to you many times before.
John 13, 34, John 15, 9, Ephesians 3, 16 to 21.
And there are others as well, of course.
So January the 30th, 1901, Jesus talks about the poison of self-interest.
This morning on coming, blessed Jesus transported me outside of myself in the midst of many people
of different conditions.
There were priests, nuns, there were secular people that is people out in the world.
In the beginning of his sorrow and beginning his sorrowful lament, he said, "My daughter,
the poison of self-interest has entered into all hearts."
Okay.
Now this self-interest is to get something from me out of what I do.
This modern thing, what's in it for me?
That's the thing he's saying is absolutely deadly.
My daughter, the poison of self-interest has entered into all hearts, and they've become
soaked with this poison like sponges.
This pestilent poison has penetrated into monasteries, into priests, and into everybody
outside and society.
My daughter, that which does not surrender to the light of truth and to the power of virtue
surrenders before a most wretched self-interest.
Now what he's saying here is that if our hidden motivations are really for ourselves
and to benefit ourselves, like you'll hear people saying, "Well, I just want to save
my own soul.
I'm not interested in anybody else."
Are there doing something which appears to be very good and praise worthy, but they're
actually doing it for the wrong reasons.
Jesus says that absolutely destroys it, and he calls it a pestilent poison.
Before this poison he said, "The most sublime and excelling virtues fall shattered like
fragile glass," isn't that sad?
And while saying this, he cried bitterly.
In other words, we are our own worst enemies.
We don't need anybody else.
There's a statement in Sam 62, I think it is, that I'm like a tottering wall and a tumbling
fence, and that actually describes us very, very well.
We're able to destroy ourselves with no help from anybody else.
Who can say the torment of my soul in seeing my most loving Jesus cry?
Not knowing what to do to make him stop crying, I spoke some nonsense, "My dear, please do
not cry.
If the others do not love you, offend you and have their eyes dazzled by the poison
of self-interest, in such a way as to remain all soaked with it, there is still me and
I love you.
I praise you and I look at all that as earthly, as rubbish, and I aspire to nothing but have
you, therefore you should be content in my love and stop crying.
And if you feel embittered, pour it on me, for I am more content with it than seeing
you cry."
So on hearing me, Jesus stopped crying and poured a little bit of his bitterness.
And then he shared with me the pains of the cross and he said, "My virtues and the merits
I acquired for man in my passion are as many towers of fortitude on which everyone can
lean along the journey, along the way to eternity."
Now, we have two major towers of fortitude and they are Jesus's own virtues and his merits
to help us along the way.
We're not alone.
But man is ungrateful.
Now, throughout the 36 volumes, the human being is described all the time as ungrateful,
ungrateful, ungrateful.
And we know that ourselves, the human beings, are not grateful for what you do for them.
But man ungrateful, running away from these towers of fortitude, leans on mud and conducts
himself along the way of tradition.
So I want to give you Matthew 7, verses 13 to 14, the narrow way and the broad way.
The broad way leads to hell and the narrow way to life.
Then Jesus disappeared.
So I also want to give you Proverbs 3, 5, "My son, lean not on your own understanding."
So January the 31st, 1901, Jesus talks about patience.
And before I begin, I want to give you some references.
Romans 5, verses 3 to 4, Hebrews 10, 36 and 12, 1.
And Revelation 14, 12, there's lots more as well, but that's, I get you going.
As I was in my usual state, my sweet Jesus was not coming.
And after much waiting, I saw him for just a little and he told me, "My daughter, patience
is superior to purity because without patience the soul easily on bridles and it is difficult
for her to remain pure."
Now what he's saying, the meaning of patience is long, suffering.
And we all have to be tested in this particular area because if we're not willing to endure
anything, then all the virtues will fall apart.
And he says, "Purity will fall apart as well," and we know that as well, that young people
just have not got the patience to wait even five minutes.
They want what they want now, or as we say, they want it yesterday.
And so without patience, purity doesn't actually stand a chance.
So let me read that again for you.
My daughter, patience is superior to purity because without patience, the soul easily
on bridles, and this is what we're seeing all around us in society today, is on bridle
glossed.
And it is difficult for her to remain pure.
And when a virtue needs another virtue in order to have life, the second one is called
superior to the first.
So purity needs patience even more.
It can be said that patience is the custody of purity.
Not only this, but it is the staircase to ascend to the mountain of fortitude.
Now for staircase, I want to give you John 1.51, where Jesus says he's the fulfillment
of Genesis 28, where Jacob saw a ladder connecting heaven and earth and angels going up and down.
So patience is the staircase to ascend to the mountain of fortitude in such a way that
if one went up without the staircase of patience, he would immediately fall from the highest
point at the lowest.
And as you know, the most painful fall is the one from a great height.
In addition to this, patience is the seed of perseverance.
And this seed produces branches called firmness.
I want to give you Sam 73 verse 4 and Hebrews 36.
Now this firmness is stability, is the word we would use.
Oh, how firm and stable, you see the two words are together now, in good that she has started,
sorry.
Oh, how firm and stable in the good she has started is the patient's soul.
Sorry, it's very bad English.
The patient's soul has started a very good journey to become firm and stable.
As she pays no attention either to rain or to frost ice or fire, but all her attention
is on bringing to completion the good that she has started.
In fact, there's no greater foolishness than that of one who today does some good because
she likes it and tomorrow it lacks it because they feel no more pleasure in it.
Matthew 725, by their fruits, you will know them.
What we want to say if an eye which had one hour possessed light and another hour was
blind or of a tongue which now speaks and then is mute, I, yes, my daughter, patience
alone is the secret key.
Now through as we go through these writings, the Lord will give us different keys that
are absolutely essential for our spiritual growth and this is one of them.
Patience is the secret key to open the treasure of virtues.
Without the secret of this key, the other virtues do not come out to give life to the
soul and to ennoble her.
That's very important because we don't hear a lot about patience in these writings so
there's a very good lesson there.
So February 5, 1901, Louisa encounters two maidens who serve justice.
This morning, blessed Jesus transported me outside of myself, but he made himself seen
in a state that moved even the stones to pity, oh how he suffered.
It seemed that unable to endure anymore, he wanted to unload himself a little, almost
asking for help.
I felt my poor heart split with tenderness and immediately I pulled the crown of thorns
from him, putting it on myself so as to give him relief.
And then I said to him, my sweet good, you've not renewed in me the pains of the cross for
some time.
I pray you to renew them in me today so that you will be more relieved.
And he said, my beloved, it is necessary to ask justice in order to do this.
Now he tries to teach you the difference between justice and love.
And of course, all of God's divine attributes are equal, they're infinitely equal.
As things have reached such a point that justice can no longer permit you to suffer, okay?
In other words, if things are so terrible that Louisa would have to make a difference,
the sufferings she would have to endure might actually kill her.
That's why you'd have to ask justice, loving love pushes her to say, yes, I'll do it.
But Jesus says justice has to temper love.
And in the next paragraph, he gives us an insight into what's really wrong in the world.
I didn't know what to do in order to ask justice, Louisa said, when two maidens came up to me
who seemed to be serving justice.
One had the name of tolerance and the other of dissimulation.
That's very interesting, because dissimulation, that points to deception, which is widespread
in society.
And other words for dissimulation is disinformation or fake news, okay?
So it means that society tolerates all kinds of evil.
So these two maidens had the name of tolerance and dissimulation.
And as I asked them to crucify me, tolerance took one of my hands and nailed it, but without
wanting to finish.
And so I said, oh, holy dissimulation, complete my crucifixion.
Don't you see that tolerance has left me?
Show yourself how much better you are in dissimulating.
So she completed my crucifixion, but with such spasm that if the Lord had not sustained
me in his arms, I would certainly have died.
In other words, the tolerance and the dissimulation represent the whole of the 20th century.
It was the century of deception.
In the 20th century, we learned how to fake everything.
It's perfectly normal for us.
We don't even give a second thought to the fact that you could be wearing a string around
your neck that looks like pearls, but you only bought them for a few pens.
They're not real.
And we have faked all kinds of beauty in art, in everything, everything in society.
And we even have fake virtues that people put on a show pretending that you're welcome
or whatever.
The example I would give you is someone going to a reception and the people receiving you
say, "Oh, you're very welcome and behind your back to say, what is she doing here?"
So there's also the fact that this tolerance thing has become a disease in our society.
We're so tolerant.
We accept all sinfulness.
We accept all that is totally against Christianity.
We accept evil in the name of tolerance.
It's really unbelievable.
So Louisa really had to suffer.
After this, Blessed Jesus said, "Daughter, it's necessary that you suffer these pains
at least sometimes and if it were not so woe to the world, what would become of it?"
And then she prayed to him for various people.
Now, February the 6th, 1901, the perfect satisfaction of Jesus is finding himself in the soul.
So what the Lord wants more than anything else is union of love with us.
As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus on coming told me, "My daughter, when my grace
is in possession of more people, it celebrates more."
When grace has the critical mass of people, then the kingdom of God triumphs.
But when sin has the critical mass, then chastisement has got to take over and try and bring some
kind of recovery into the system.
It happens as to queens.
The more maidens that hang upon their wishes and surround them like a crown, the more they
enjoy and make feast.
You should fix yourself in me.
You should look at me and you will be so taken by me that everything material will drop dead
for you.
I want to give you Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You shall love the Lord your God with all your heart and all your soul, all your mind
and all your being.
You must fix yourself in me so much as to draw me completely into yourself in such a way
that finding myself in you I may find in you my perfect satisfaction.
So as I find in you all possible pleasures I could find in a human creature what the others
do to me cannot grieve me so much.
So what the Lord needs is more and more and more people who really genuinely love him and
who genuinely live for him and want him alone and the more of us who do that the more he
has a place to live on earth and that he can look with more compassion on the others because
of us.
And while saying this he closed himself up inside of me and was all pleased.
Now fortunate I would consider myself if I arrived at drawing my beloved Jesus completely
into myself.
She already has him she just doesn't acknowledge it.
So February the 10th 1901 we're back to obedience again.
As my adorable Jesus continued to come he made himself seen with eyes refulgent with most
vivid and pure light.
So let's one John one five God is light.
I was enchanted and surprised before this dazzling light now as you go on in the in these volumes
that dazzling light you will be told quite simply is the divine will.
And Jesus on seeing me so enchanted and speechless said to me my beloved obedience has extremely
long sight and surpasses the very light of the sun in beauty and in sharpness in the
same way love of self which we were talking about a few moments ago is very short sighted.
So much so that it cannot take a step without tripping and do not believe that this extremely
long sight is possessed by those souls who go on always disturbed.
Now we've been told since volume one that we must not allow any interior disturbance
in us because that disturbance allows the the demon to attack and keeps the Lord out
because Jesus only works in complete calm because he is the king of peace.
So so I'll repeat this again.
Do not believe that this extremely long sight is possessed by those souls who go on always
disturbed and in scruplessness now scruplessness was a problem in the early in not in the early
church in the early part of the 20th century.
People thought there was some kind of holiness in being scrupless and in these writings Jesus
makes it perfectly clear that that scruplessness is giving super attention to yourself and
it's it's nothing to do with love and all the rest of it.
Saint Therese of Liz you had to battle with that and to overcome it until she came through
to being completely love.
So rather this is a net that love of self weaves around them.
But there is your explanation of scruplessness, okay, it's a net of love of self.
The person is completely wound up with themselves thinking about themselves all the time which
being very short sighted make them fall first and then provokes in them a thousand disturbances
and scruples and because they keep on analyzing it.
And what they have detested today with so many scruples and fears they fall into again
tomorrow.
And the reason is that they're not allowing love to dominate, they're not allowing love
to take over, love would push all of that aside and get on with loving God and loving
the neighbor.
So they fall again into it tomorrow to the point that their living is reduced to being
always immersed in this artificial net.
Artificious is cleverly contrived net.
In other words it's a very clever way of Satan to keep us all locked up in ourselves and
not even looking up enough to find out if God is there or my neighbor is there.
So to the point that their living is reduced to being always immersed in this artificial
or very cleverly contrived net which love of self knows well how to weave around them
and the devil of course is thrilled.
This unlikely unlike the extremely long sight of obedience which is the killer of the love
of self that is why we're being shown all the time that Louisa is being exercised to
the excess in obedience because the Lord is trying to show us that the divine will cannot
reign in us if the human will is reigning and if the love of self is reigning then the love
of God cannot reign in us.
So this is very clear and if you put this with the teachings in volumes one and two
about self denial and mortification and all the rest of it you see very clearly how to
get free.
So the extremely long sight of obedience is the killer of the love of self.
Our sight is so very long and clear she can see things clearly whereas with scruplessness
you don't say it's like being in a fog that immediately she foresees where she might slip
and with generous heart she abstains from it there's your self denial and mortification
and enjoys the holy freedom of the children of God which Paul describes wonderfully in
Romans chapter 8.
And just as darkness draws more darkness so does the light draw more light and this light
arrives at drawing to itself the light of the word and uniting together they weave the
light of all the virtues there's a wonderful thing.
So the more we move towards love we're moving towards light and the more love and light
take over the more God is able to operate within us.
Surprised on hearing this because scruplessity was considered somehow a holy thing in the
early 20th century.
Louisa said Lord what are you saying?
To me it seems that the scrupless way of living is sanctity and he with a more serious
tone he said on the contrary I tell you this is the true mark of obedience while that is
the true mark of love of self and that way of living moves me more to indignation than
to love and the reason is that the people with this scruplessness and all this wrapped
up in themselves are the priests and the nuns and the brothers who are supposed to be loving
God and loving their neighbors and keeping the church alive and well and Satan is wrapping
them all up in these terrible nets of self love.
In fact when it is the light of truth that allows one to see one's false be it even in
the slightest way there should be some inundation the book says there should be some improvement
but since it is the short site of the love of self it does nothing but keep them oppressed
having no development on the path of true sanctity so there is Jesus trying to correct
something that is really wrong in the way people are living the spiritual life in 1901.
February the 17th 1901 this is about our origin where we came from.
This morning as I was all oppressed and in suffering Louisa said I saw my beloved Jesus
for just a little as well as many people immersed in many miseries.
Then breaking the silence he had kept for many days he said my daughter man is born in me
first that is in eternity receiving the imprint of the divinity that's Genesis 1 27 and Genesis
2 7 that's the image of God that's the imprint of the divinity.
Then as he goes out of me to be reborn in the maternal womb in time that is so the first
one is in eternity I give him the command to walk a little stretch of the way and at the
end of that way letting myself be found by him I receive him again back into myself making
him live eternally with me so this is the circle of our lives.
See now how noble man is where he comes from and where he goes and what his destiny is.
Now should the sanctity of this man what should the sanctity of this man be coming out of
a God who is so holy but in covering the way to come to me again man destroys that of the
divine which he has received he destroys much of the divine that he has received and that's
with our sins.
He corrupts himself in such a way that at the encounter I have with him to receive him
into myself I no longer recognize him I no longer see the divine imprint in him I find
nothing of my own in him so the love joy peace patience kindness and goodness of Galatians
520 is missing the fruits of the spirit and no longer recognizing him my justice condemns
him as a lost soul to go wandering the way of perdition that's sad now the description
of man here corrupting himself is the description of the prodigal son in Luke 15 because Jesus
tells us that that the whole human race is actually the prodigal son created by God destroyed
by a man how tendered was to hear Jesus speak about this how many things he made me understand
but my state of suffering doesn't permit me to write anymore.
March the 8th 1901 we're talking about the cross continuing in my poor state and with
the silence of blessed Jesus this morning as I was oppressed more than ever on coming
he said to me my daughter it was not my works nor my preaching nor the very power of my miracles
that made me recognized with clarity as the God I am but was when I was put on the cross
and lifted up on it as though on my own throne then I was recognized okay he said that already
in John chapter 3 I can't remember the verse when I am lifted up from the earth I will
draw all men to myself John 828 and John 12 32 to 34 so it was when you go through the
hours of the agony of Jesus on the cross in the hours of the passion you'll see clearly
what he's referring to here is that everybody was completely astonished having tortured Jesus
beyond recognition that his responses were completely divine to the point where his executioner
said that man was a son of God he was something else and became one of one of his disciples
long genus so the cross alone revealed me to the world and to the whole of hell for who
I really was now hell would recognize him the moment he forgave everybody father forgive
them they don't realize what they're doing only heaven can do that hell was completely
lost at that particular point all were shaken and recognize their creator okay because their
creator that they were looking at on the cross is in one John 4 7 to 17 that God is perfect
love and what they were looking at on the cross was perfect love therefore it is the
cross that reveals God to the soul and makes known whether the soul is truly of God or not
it can be said that the cross uncovers all the intimate parts of the soul and reveals
to God and to men who she is well it's only as we go through the terrible crosses in life
that who we really are is actually revealed as well it's absolutely amazing and then
he added upon two crosses I consume souls one of these crosses is pain and the other is
love now St. Therese of Lesus actually consecrated herself to be a victim of divine love and
she experienced in a very real way but on a spiritual level the passion of Jesus in her
dying and just as in heaven all nine choirs of angels love me though each one has its
distinct office as for example the special office of the seraphim is love and their choir
is positioned more in the front naturally enough because God is love in order to receive the
reverberations of my love so much so that my love and theirs darting through each other
correspond continuously in the same way I give to souls on earth their distinct offices
some I render martyrs of pain others I render martyrs of love as both of them are skillful
masters in sacrificing souls and in rendering them worthy of my satisfactions so what is
reflected in heaven in the choirs of angels is reflected on earth in the different types
of martyrdom that the Lord calls people into now I'm going to leave it there just for the
moment.